welcome to this video playing
international master Worley from the UK
jack so what's the name John Paul
Wallace okay playing the some BOGO
Indian set up quite an interesting line
to play with you a five and a quick
preparation of D 69 d 75 ok so now many
ways to play that can capture and what
inform what do I just take here and play
nike form you just blunder deep one
right and he just blundered the upon
from no compensation whatsoever the only
slight thing in his favor sir the
diagonal but it's not not too much of a
problem okay if I go f6 I could get into
trouble with this should be form should
be five someone i can go here protect
the pawn with the Queen yeah I don't
need to make sure that the diagonal
stays close to this is strange I check
it isn't it just gone
oh this is a weird game one of those
games where I don't understand just a
single move by by the other guy okay
Queen I take you can take g6 okay okay
just keep it simple check the apt
reigning queens should be flat out when
the end came from black bikini Sam
looked yet I can also play a 4 yeah this
is maybe the easiest way to go a4 look a
5 Luke c5 now it's also a good idea it's
just a lost structure all this all those
weaknesses
what I'm trying to do is not to fall too
much behind on the clock the absolutely
only chance is goddess that I'm doing
some silly stuff on the clock okay so
look up here
yeah I need to go there should be six
thought your third row h 1 now I can
play rook a 5c 5 just just grabbing this
thing
yeah but don't expect even a single move
I far group edge one still um ok
in 10 min King c5 King c5 and then be
sick special e-cigs he's a bit tight
with his pieces he cannot move any of
those pieces okay so it says some
technical solution on yeah i can i can
just regroup here look h8 h 3 and
something like that you still cannot
move any of those pieces now be five
wins winsor the bishop Jim okay but this
is also strong check
winning all the pawns f2 threatening
Bishop f5 okay white resigned yeah i
justjust blonde at the e4 pawn in the
opening and basically after that it's a
it's just it's just terrible okay maybe
you can defend it better because right
here why doesn't a sinner in a lost
structure the bad Queen side let's it's
still a porn down the Sun is an
additional problem yeah this is
basically just a loss can't you could
have could have defended better of
course a bit at least I thought it just
advanced a couple of news here I thought
I thought rook h1 trying to enter here I
have this one but still I felt that
something like this would be but I can
just take a two-way emphasis this is a
strong porn I still felt that this would
be a bit a bit tougher but it's a win
nevertheless I think the position is
really beyond repair after you you
blunder the pond I mean maybe some some
better way to defend but the central
porn for no compensation is basically
too much to give away okay thanks for
watching